is about you and your opinions if you're
thinking about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Petersburg uncensored in New
York City the face and voice of
Britain's National broadcaster Hugh
Edwards is dramatically named as a
suspended BBC presenter at the center of
a scandal are alleged sex images that
script the country Edward's wife Vicki
Flynn released a statement tonight
naming her husband and detailing his
serious mental health issues explaining
is now receiving treatment in hospital
we'll have all the latest on this huge
story plus is a Kennedy a
controversialist now a candidate for
president of the United States RFK Jr
rattled the race for the White House by
daring to say many things that nobody
else will and a lot of people are
supporting him but can he win he joins
me live
[Music]
live from New York this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening and welcome from New
York City to Piers Morgan on census
difficult to overstate how big of a deal
it is back in Britain that Hugh Edwards
the face of British news really the face
of BBC News has now been named as the
presenter at the center of this huge
Scandal that's been raging in the last
week in that esteem he's the face of our
state occasions of Royal events he's the
man who announced the death of the late
Queen he's right he's authoritative and
above all he's always been trusted by
all accountancy audiences love him I
know him personally he's always seemed
to be a very stand-up guy so today's
news that he is the presenter behind the
BBC sex picture scandal is a huge shock
to everyone that knows him maybe to his
family certainly to millions of people
who are used to watching him on the news
each night uh probably a shock to his
colleagues at the BBC the last five days
speculation has raged about the man at
the heart of the crisis tonight his wife
Vicki Flynn the television producer with
whom he has five children took the
courageous decision to end all that
speculation in a statement she said I'm
doing this primarily out of concern for
his mental well-being and to protect our
children he is suffering from serious
mental health issues as is well
documented he's been treated with severe
depression in recent years the events of
the last few days are greatly worse than
matters he suffered another serious
episode and is now receiving inpatient
hospital care we'll stay for the
foreseeable future one's well enough to
do so he intends to respond to the
stories that have been published she
goes on to confirm that Edwards didn't
know about any of his claims until last
week she made a call for privacy and she
adds that Hugh is deeply sorry that so
many colleagues had been impacted by the
speculation and that's a key Point
especially the speculation was becoming
completely unsustainable many other male
BBC presenters were being shamed and
vilified on social media for something
that had nothing to do with and had to
in some cases publicly deny their
involvement viewers were bound to notice
that Hugh Edwards had banished overnight
from the Nightly News bulletins now
clearly Hugh Edwards is now in a very
serious situation Nation he probably
feels like he's losing everything
whatever the outcome of the
investigations it would be inhuman not
to think about the impact of all this on
him on his family his mental health all
of those are important things to
consider now but now we can talk freely
about who this is it should also be
clear why it's been such a big story The
Met police says it has no evidence of
criminality but what remains are
allegations about a potentially serious
abuse of power by a household name paid
handsomely from the public purse accused
originally of paying tens of thousands
of pounds to a teenager with drug
problems for indecent images more claims
about his behavior have followed from
three other people so far including
allegations made not just to the Sun but
directly to the BBC and the way that BBC
has managed this complaint remains a
matter of legitimate public interest and
concern we shouldn't forget the other
people involved in the story because
there are a lot well I'm joined Now by
my pack the best-selling author of War
of the West and columnist Douglas Murray
former conservative MP Louise Mensch and
the multi-millionaire investor one of
the sharks the American reality tank
Kevin O'Leary the former executive
channel five and also worked at the BBC
David elstein but first let me start by
talking to the former BBC political
correspondent and current times radio
presenter Carol Walker Carol thank you
so much for joining me um this is a
unbelievably complex and difficult story
has been from the start because I'm sure
you like me and most people in the media
very quickly discovered that it was Hugh
Edwards
um but that name was not being made
public and as a result there was this
Feeding Frenzy of speculation driven by
social media about who this could be
that was of course Very damaging to all
those concerned but as somebody who
knows Hugh web as well what is your
reaction to all this uh turn of events
today the police saying that they found
no evidence on that initial story of any
crime being committed and secondly his
wife's decision to go public in naming
him and revealing he's having these
serious mental health issues in hospital
well I think to be honest peers my first
thoughts are for Hughes family and for
Hugh himself he's clearly uh had a very
serious mental health problem he is
being treated in hospital for that and
it must have been an unbelievably
difficult time for his wife and the rest
of his family she's clearly taken the
decision that she had to speak out
tonight uh that can't have been easy and
I think that really we do have to
respect and understand why she's now
asking for some time for the rest of the
family to try and ensure that he gets
the right treatment and and to get on
with their own lives I think the other
important thing to say here appears is
that of course none of the allegations
about who has actually been proven or
established Beyond any doubt the police
have now said that they are not going to
carry out any sort of investigation and
I think that what we're left with here
is though there are clearly some
questions about how the BBC may have
handled this it does underline the
complexity of all of this you know I
worked alongside Hugh when he was uh a
rising star as a political correspondent
one of a number of very ambitious and
talented BBC figures including some of
those uh like Jeremy Vine who found
themselves unfairly targeted and I think
that it does also just highlight that
issue of how people who are such huge
public figures uh can also then find
themselves targets not just perhaps of
some Justified complaints but also of
such huge amounts of speculation and
rumors as we've seen over the past few
days swirling around on social media
yeah I mean it's not don't disagree with
any of that all I would say though is it
seems to be a sort of growing uh
criticism of the way the sun has handled
this but to be clear they didn't name
him to start with and they didn't say
that what he'd done was a criminal act
that was others actually that were
commenting on this potentially straying
into the area criminality also
significantly the BBC themselves have
also been exposing their own stories
from their own investigation into Hugh
Urban's alleged inappropriate conduct in
fact today I think there were more
Revelations from the BBC about his
allegedly inappropriate behavior towards
colleagues so it's not just a tabloid or
a sun-driven scandal in that sense
you've actually had to BBC themselves
having journalists investigating and
finding what they believed to be because
they reported it to be evidence of
inappropriate conduct where does that
leave Hugh Edwards do you think in terms
of his future at the BBC and what do you
feel about the BBC actually in that
situation investigating him in that way
well look I actually think that the BBC
has done a pretty good job on reporting
a story which is about one of its own
very senior presenters I think anyone
who has watched the BBC coverage over
the past few days
um cat must really accept and
acknowledge that they've managed to
treat this as another story I have
worked at the BBC when there are stories
about the BBC I know how difficult it is
um but I know that it's also a point of
Pride for the BBC that it's journalists
try to set aside the fact that it is one
of their own that they're talking about
and to treat this as another news story
now you and I both now work for
competitors
um but we'll know what the challenges
are in the journalism of this sort of
thing so uh I think Tim Davey himself
the director General uh has acknowledged
that perhaps they need to look again at
their complaints process at the
procedures when a complete planed
against a senior figure is red flagged
or something that's very serious I think
there are perhaps some legitimate
questions about whether they moved
swiftly enough but you have to balance
that against the fact that there are a
huge numbers of complaints made every
week about BBC figures just to I think
just to pick you up on that there are
but I don't think there'll be many
complaints of this severity against the
face of BBC News would be my counter
that I still think it's ridiculous to
BBC in seven weeks after this was
reported to them by the family directly
about their concerns about what was
happening with their son that it took
seven weeks and just one standard email
and one phone call that didn't get
connected that was their attempt of
following up what was obviously on the
face of it potentially extremely serious
charges as indeed Tim Davey the director
General the BBC has conceded they were
so I wouldn't necessarily go along I
think with your defense of the way the
BBC handled it I should think it's been
a little bit shambolic but yeah
up on that point Pierce because you
should also bear in mind that the young
person at the center of the very first
allegation the allegation that Hugh
Edwards as we now know it is had paid
money uh to someone uh for explicit
images the young person at the center of
that said the claims that were made and
reported in the sun about this uh were
rubbish and that there had been nothing
illegal or improper that had taken place
so there are also two sides to that and
neither
anyone else listen knows the truth of
that at the moment yeah I don't I don't
have any uh inside knowledge of what the
sun has in terms of evidence but what I
do know is this young man is clearly uh
pretty damaged he's uh apparently a
crack cocaine addict so I'm not entirely
sure that we should take everything he
may be saying after this
um as as you know I'd love to have him
on the program and talk about it but I
don't think he can so I think it's
complicated let me go to David
top major executive used to work at the
BBC David from a corporate position as a
television executive
how do you think the BBC have handled
this and what do they do now about Hugh
Edwards
well I I think they've mishandled it but
for a completely different reason I'm
actually quite shocked to discover that
the BBC has an internal investigations
unit which uh might inquire into its
employees private lives I think that's
wholly inappropriate and uh I'm I hope
the first thing that happens is that
that unit is shut down
um look when the complainant first uh
appeared uh they said there has been no
uh according to the police whom they
talked to there's been no criminality so
what is the BBC meant to do
what when someone says one of your
employees has been sending uh my child a
lot of money it's not crying what where
is the BBC's role in all of this so to
say okay let me let me pick you up on
that on that point though does it need
to be a crime to still be inappropriate
behavior by the head of BBC News hey
hang on a minute uh how do we know
there's inappropriate bedroom and is
paying somebody 35 000 pounds
inappropriately I mean you can afford to
pay for someone 35 000 pounds I'm sure
would uh talk TV then fire you for doing
so uh I think it depends I think I think
there are lots of unanswered questions I
agree but to my knowledge so far there's
been no denial of the payment of 35 000
pounds to a young person who we know is
apparently addicted to crack cocaine
that does seem to me to probably stray
into the area if you're running the BBC
of potentially inappropriate conduct by
the head of their news division isn't it
it well it's not the head of the news
division is that lead presented it's the
face of it is the face of it yeah of
course but if uh the story if the song
publishes stuff which definitively shows
that Hugh Edwards did things which uh
bring the BBC into distribute of course
the BBC would then be entitled to say
you're a breacher contract we suspend
you we don't renew your contract we five
all of those things but it's not for the
BBC to be an arm of the police to be an
arm of the National Health Service as
was being suggested in the last uh panel
discussion you know sending help to drug
addicts how do we know that this young
person is a severely damaged crack
cocaine addict we only hear it through
the Sun from his mother and stepmother
and he denies everything that they say
so if I were the BBC I'd be no further
on than the police have been in saying
nothing to see here so okay my view of
this is the BBC were quite wrong to turn
to allow it to be turned into a BBC
story it was a story about a BBC
employee a big story about a BBC
employee but chances are that he was
going to be uh resigning or taking sick
leave or whatever into two calls anyway
but okay BBC to insert itself into the
investigative process was inappropriate
and wrong okay David thank you thank you
Carol all right let's come to my panel
here in New York Douglas we've heard
you've heard two people there and their
views what's your what's your view about
this story
um my view is is I mean essentially the
British public have been watching on in
recent months it looks like a very bad
time to be a television presenter in
Britain at the moment doesn't it and
there's something sort of baffling I
think the general public about this
there have been these two massive
scandals of two of the most prominent
faces in television Schofield and that's
Hugh Edwards I do think I think there
are lots of things to take in mind I I
agree with some of what's been said I
mean effectively we're back into the old
problem of actually it's a it's a
problem at the BBC of oversight of BBC
procedures the BBC of course always
quite understandably comes into the
headlights and the firing line of
everybody else because you know
everybody's got criticism of the BBC the
BBC always tries to please every party
and very often it fails to please any
party uh so it seems to be it's
something to do with BBC governance and
oversight that's the issue here uh I'd
say two other things one is the whole
thing of you know
we have to go to mental health hospitals
and all this sort of thing you know men
are idiots and men are idiots a lot and
I do think that the sort of
pathologizing of men making mistakes
into always having to be a mental health
issue is you know maybe something to be
discussed another day but it is a
problem that the second thing I'd just
add to that is that whenever we look at
a case like this you know we've just got
to remember that there are a lot of
different agendas that are going to go
on behind this there are going to be
people who are going to come out with
for team Hugh Edwards they're going to
be not that many at the moment there are
going to be others that come out for you
know the the young men and we've just
heard about the possibility of this
young man is a well-adjusted crack
cocaine right I don't think is very
likely at all
um but but you know it's it's just it's
just a difficult ugly and complex story
I don't look to newscasters for to moral
guidance I don't look to them for good
behavior or anything else but much of
the country just doesn't want to know
about the private life of Hugh Edwards
it's now out there and for him I'd have
thought that's just a career-wise a
terrible place to be in Louise I I think
there's a lot of feelings you can have
about this you can feel sorry for Hugh
Edwards he's in this awful condition
he's in hospital he's got he's a
well-documented uh depressive he's had
problems with this before on a human
level I know him a bit I feel sorry for
the situation he's in but I also need to
know more about what's been going on
before you can I think make any broad
brush stroke judgments about what he's
done wrong and what the BBC should do in
response to that given that he is
effectively the face of BBC News I don't
there are two separate
issue he's depressed depressed and he's
been depressed for a long time I'm very
sorry for him for that genuinely that's
terrible what he has done allegedly to
these vulnerable young people is
something else altogether and listening
to your other guests I wonder if we're
reading the same story because I heard
absolutely nothing of concern for the
alleged victims that have come forward
so far also let me just say right now
it's not true that these allegations all
of the allegations are unproven the
second accuser didn't go to the sun they
went directly to the BBC and they said I
didn't want to meet up offline he
bullied me he threatened me and the BBC
themselves reported that they had
checked Hugh Edwards as we now know
phone and that yes indeed those
threatening messages came from him so if
everybody I think should stop
um
feeling sorry for Mr Edwards in terms of
what he allegedly did to these people
that's not okay and I also do think that
we have to draw a distinction between
conduct that's illegal which the police
say there's no evidence of and conduct
that's unethical and that's immoral the
BBC is funded by everybody in Britain
through the license fee of you pay TV
you have to pay the BBC we do have a
right to ask its highest paid employees
that maybe they should have some care
for young people not threaten them not
bully them that we know factually did
actually happen is that okay would it be
okay in any other Organization no it's
interesting to me to see this sort of
sun bashing that's going on against the
beastly tabloids doing all this the BBC
have now done two separate exposes a few
webwards in the last 48 hours about his
alleged inappropriate behavior including
today reportedly towards colleagues at
the BBC that's something to do with the
sun that's to do with the BBC themselves
unearthing stuff that they believe is
worthy of reporting so it's much more
nuanced I think than people are trying
to make out this is just the sun
invading his privacy I don't think it's
as simple as that at all Kevin you've
been sitting very patiently listening to
all this I guess your perspective of
interesting to me is from a purely
business point of view you've got a guy
the BBC is a global brand it's a global
brand that really requires trust it's
paid for by the British taxpayer and
that carries with it the brand of the
BBC total trust you know that's his
great sort of calling card if you like
when when the face of BBC News the
person chosen to announce the death of
the Monarch for example when that person
is seen to have behaved in this alleged
way in his private life even if it
doesn't stray into criminality and we
still don't know that yet over all these
allegations
would the behavior itself be
inappropriate enough to justify the BBC
firing him and should they have handled
this differently from the moment they
first had the allegations come to them
it's the question because I look at it
from several verticals the BBC as an
institution and a brand in the financial
markets worldwide is one of the three
Outlets that all of us listen to every
day because we look for five major
stories to make financial decisions on
daily it starts in North America here at
about five in the morning and the BBC
has a different spin on all of them that
North American Outlets have or even
Canadian there's an equivalent
organization called the CBC in Canada
which is often listened to by New York
Financial managers as well for for the
North American continent but this
volatility in presenters and columnists
on all sides of the pond has been
extreme in the last 12 months because
we're trying to figure out how do you
maintain the brand and as you've just
spoke to the CBC will this change in any
way my viewership which has now been 50
years I've been watching the BBC almost
daily for 50 years 50 years from are you
lived in Cyprus for a while Tunisia
Cambodia Ethiopia the BBC is where we
got our news I was Globe hopping for
decades and so
in two weeks will this make any
difference and the answer is no this
narrative in the next 24 hours is going
to shift away from Hugh and and I feel
sorry as as we all do the pressure he
must be under but I'd add this to it
when you dedicate your life to be a
presenter or a news reader as we call
them here in America you have to give up
certain things and there's no question
about this if you have flaws in your
personality you're dealing with your own
demon because there is no question 100
percent that one day they will cause
your demise as a presenter or columnist
because there is zero tolerance at the
institutional ever whether it's BBC or
any American Network or streaming
service today zero tolerance and the way
you can measure this is look at the
morality Clauses that have made their
way into every presentation that's true
absolutely I and that's changed in the
last 36 months every Network that puts a
presenter on as a contributor whether
they're a columnist or a news reader has
a morality clause in it so that you can
pull that rip cord and to the is the
extent that you can save the institution
because
she there is no coming back from this
even if half of these allegations are
true
but he unfortunately will not be part of
the narrative in 24 hours Douglas let me
just ask you about the aspect of his
sexuality here's a guy is married with
five kids he's talked about being a
regular churchgoer and so on and he
appears to have been you know having
some kind of relationship with young men
and we don't know the exact nature of
what that is but apparently he was
exchanging for money for sexually
explicit pictures and so on that's one
of the reasons why he wasn't named
originally was because you can't out
people in this day and age the media and
they would get into big trouble if they
did so in a way he was sort of oddly
protected in that sense that was Philip
Schofield well for a while yeah and that
is a concern should it matter I mean if
your hero was in your presenting the
news should it matter if you have a
confused sexuality if you're leading a
double life whatever does that actually
matter to your ability to read the news
and be trusted to do so well I don't
think so I mean as I said I think
there's a there's a problem always a
problem in the BBC about over side and
the BBC always gets into trouble because
it tries to cover things over you know
that's been the case historically and it
is a tax fair but pay a funded
institution it's different from other
media and so perhaps it's right to have
a different set of expectations but as
as for the sort of morality thing as I
said before and I don't look to news
readers for Morality but there's
something very strange that is going on
in Britain at the moment I'm actually
with my column about this in The
Spectator this week is
um the public behave in a different way
to the expectations we have of a lot of
public figures I mean a lot of the
public are on dating apps if it's true
that Hugh Edwards was on a dating app
and nothing illegal happened
uh uh do we expect well that is really
only accountable isn't he Louise to his
wife and family exactly isn't it
countable ultimately I mean absolutely
but here's where I object to people
saying this is about Hugh Edward's
private life no it isn't if your Edwards
had just had a boyfriend a male lover
and everything was free and equal
between them then it's none of our bees
Works absolutely and the BBC shouldn't
be looking into it those aren't the
allegations it's not an allegation about
Hugh Edwards private life it's an
allegation of causing harm to others
bullying threatening and so forth that's
where it steps out of your private life
whatever you're saying and again just to
repeat all those allegations are coming
from the BBC themselves and their own
independent investigations into their
star presenter and I think when the
media trial starts as it already is yeah
fine if you want to try and criticize
the son who never named him but the BBC
have been doing their own reporting and
unearthing material they believe is
worthy of reporting him is alleged
inappropriately including to BBC
colleagues the BBC should thank the Sun
for doing the job that they themselves
so woefully failed to do the second
accuser who came directly to the BBC
wouldn't have come forward if the first
story hadn't broken right in the sun
thank you to my panel great to see you
Kevin thank you very much for coming on
I appreciate you pivoting to this big
Story coming out of our pond but as you
say you've been a BBC viewer for 50
years so probably nobody more expert to
talk about it so I appreciate you
joining us today and thank you to
Douglas and to Louise I appreciate it
rather next RFK Jr has been called the
black sheep of America's most famous
political Dynasty he's also though
shaking up the race for the White House
and he joins me live can he be the next
president of the United States we'll
find out after the break
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Liberty there and of course that is the
symbol of freedom and democracy in the
United States and nothing symbolizes
that more than the presidential race my
next guest is shaking up the race for
the White House he's come from pretty
well nowhere to be an Insurgent
Challenger to President Biden and when
he speaks people are listening
he's a Kennedy a controversialist and
now a candidate for president of the
United States
RFK Jr seen by some as the black sheep
of America's most famous political
Dynasty both his uncle President John F
Kennedy and his father Robert F Kennedy
were assassinated
Robert Jr blames the CIA Congress found
that yeah it was a plot it was a
conspiracy just as he blames vaccines
for autism and Wi-Fi for cancer Wi-Fi
radiation
is uh Craig does all kinds of bad things
including causing cancer while some cry
conspiracy many simply see a leader is
ready to rock the establishment and it's
paying off 49 of respondents say
Democrat presidential candidate Robert F
Kennedy Jr is viewed favorably by voters
higher than President Biden who want to
be podcast president is winning over
liberals tired of Biden and Republicans
tired of trump but as this ripped
Renegade really ready to be president
well Robert F Kennedy Jr joins me now
to see you good to meet you great to
meet you
um I interviewed you a few weeks ago at
the very start of all this I've got to
say you're having a great race I mean
this is really for you I would say of
all the candidates on either side you're
the one getting most attention
yeah I mean it's been uh so far so good
I'm mad
I think I me and my whole team are very
happy with how things will be going
we're getting tremendous traction all
over the country our polling data shows
uh you know me
um surging oh we're happy
let me ask you because viewers were
asking me last time what's up with his
voice they didn't know they didn't know
you they hadn't heard you speak before
let's talk about that what is the issue
with your voice I had a very I had a
very very strong voice
until I was 42 years old in 1996 I had
an injury uh that caused a neurological
disorder called spasmodic dystonia
and it makes my voice like this I cannot
listen to my voice I when I go home I
will not listen to this program really I
can't do it and I feel sorry for the
people in your audience who have to
listen to me but this is the best I've
got right now but I am
you know I went over with my wife Cheryl
Hines to do a surgery in Kyoto in Japan
about eight months ago and it made my
voice a lot more reliable and now I'm
doing a bunch of alternative uh sort of
therapies that make it I think they're
making it a lot stronger so we'll see
what happens because you must be when
you're on the trail like this you're
doing so many interviews and and
stumpings and so on I mean you use your
voice all the time does it worry you
that it may just sort of pack up or no
because my voice actually doesn't get
weaker when I use it it gets stronger
really yeah because it's not it's not
tissue injury so my my you know my vocal
cords are very very strong it's just the
neurological signals that are being sent
to them are are telling them to tighten
up all the time and it makes my voice
Gravely but
I can talk 20 hours a day and I've
always won't wear out so I'm not worried
about that but well I don't like the way
it sounds and I you know I apologize to
everybody any apologies necessarily
people are just curious
um and actually it's what comes out of
your voice it's more interesting and
more relevant to the fact that you want
to be president you come from American
royalty the Kennedy family
obviously they've had a president
they've had others who were running for
president uh why do you want to be
president what's your burning
Focus here as to why you know I I was I
did not spent a lifetime
of thinking about someday I'm going to
run for president I a bunch of things
happen particularly since covet over
the last 18 years I've been subject to a
lot of censorship on the issue of
vaccines so most people if they you know
call me people call me any vaccine but
I'm not a vaccine
and I'm called that in order to silence
me and I've been silenced in you know
many many ways for for the last 18 years
but particularly since covid
when there was Blanket censorship around
the country
um and in the UK and everywhere people
you know doctors who were reporting uh
injuries and their patients from the
vaccines or reporting success from early
treatments like Ivermectin and
hydroxychloric and we're all silenced
because that was not part of the
political narrative
and the frustration that censorship and
now you know there was a case that uh
155 page opinion that was issued earlier
this week
by a judge
um in Missouri
um about uh enjoying the White House
from censoring people anymore and it's a
large part of that decision is about the
censorship of Me by the Biden White
House I was the first person censored so
Biden came into office on January 21st
2021 and on January 23rd
Twitter and the other social media sites
refused or
received orders from the White House to
de-platform me and then three when I
certainly think that a lot of the
censorship that went on during covert on
on many fronts was completely wrong
looking back over it and shouldn't have
been happening let me just ask you have
you ever had a vaccine for anything
have I had vaccines I I was fully
compliant
what have you had in your life I mean
vaccines well I had all the vaccines you
know when I was a kid I took the three
vaccines with no then required now my
kids generation there were 72 vaccines
required in this country 72 dose of 16
vaccines
but I was traveling a lot as a kid I
went to Africa I wanted America and
everything so I received that entire
battery that you used to receive so I
probably received more vaccines than
most people in my generation and your
kids will have vaccines my my kids were
all fully vaccinated now so you're not
intrinsically anti-vaccine oh I was
never any vaccine all I want is is the
Safety Science
I think that we should have
placebo-controlled trials which are
required for every other medical product
prior to licensing vaccines and
unfortunately vaccines are exempt from
those they're the only medicine or
medical products that are exempt from
pre-licensing safety trials and you know
and therefore we do not know
what the risk profile for any of these
products are and we do not know for any
particular of those 72 doses
whether they are averting more problems
they're causing and I just think we
ought to know that I also don't believe
that we should have mandates I think you
know matters the government should not
be well I certainly think once the once
it was established that you could
transmit the virus covid whether you've
been vaccinated or not then it becomes a
personal choice I think the once that
was established to me that argument
about mandate it was was nonsensical
let's take a short break I don't spend
the whole interview talking about
vaccines you tend to do that a lot
probably not for a choice
all through choice so we've done that
let's come back and talk about about you
I know you're a falconer you're like
white water rafting you like a thrill
and a and a danger in your life I want
to get into that after the break more
from Robert Kennedy Jr
but his Hawks and his white water
rafting
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
thank you
welcome back to Facebook live from New
York City I'm with my guest Robert F
Kennedy Jr
what was the best and worst thing about
being a Kennedy
I I I
you know what I think the good
vastly outweighs the bad
uh I I don't I don't see anything to
complain about honestly you know I think
there's been so many I feel so blessed I
feel a privilege to be a member of this
family and
you know not only because of the sort of
the the cash and prize of the
connections that you have in the access
and the education and then it's you know
I have a 11 brothers and sisters and 29
cousins and we all
love each other and and you argue a lot
right I mean you yeah we were we were
trained to argue
um and my my grandfather did that with
his nine kids
you would make them you know every night
at the dinner table take opposite uh
I'll do that with my kids I think it's
healthy yeah I think it is too and I you
know I think you need to we never we
need to learn to talk with each other
dispute to have conversation and
discourse without hating each other I
totally agree this this you know I came
from an era when I was young you go down
the pub and you'd have an argument and
you'd buy each other a pint and that was
it you didn't fall out with people
because you disagree with them well you
know my Uncle Teddy Kennedy who is in
the senate for 50 years and he has more
legislation attached to his name than
any senator in the United States history
and the reason for that is he was he had
so many friends on the Republican side
of the aisle
he'd come home on weekends to the cape
where we all live in kind of a communal
group and he'd bring Orrin Hatch who is
you know to us kind of a right-wing
Darth Vader
and spent uh you know we'd spend the
weekend on a boat with him and you know
to see Teddy laughing with him and
really just enjoying and loving that's
how he should be it's how he should be
um and he never compromised his values
right but you don't have to but you can
certainly have your views challenged by
people that don't agree without losing
your mind let me ask you I mean you
Robert you were nine when your uncle
John F Kennedy was assassinated you were
14 when your father
was assassinated they're very formative
years I've got three sons who both you
know all three of them came through
those ages very formative years for such
cataclysmic things to happen what what
impact do you think those two huge
events had on your life
well I you know I think they were
National traumas
and they were part of the national
traumas you know they were basically
kind of five or six dramas uh Martin
Luther King's death my uncle my father
the Vietnam War
uh the and uh 911 and covet that pushed
our country in a bad Direction down the
road to be you know the military
industrial complex and and it becoming
kind of a surveillance State at home
but for my own personal point of view
you know my mom told us something when
we were really um told me something when
one of my brothers died
and I said to her does that that's the
hole that they leave in you when they
died is that ever get any smaller
and she said no it never gets any
smaller but our job is to grow ourselves
bigger around the whole by taking the
best parts of that the best virtues of
that person who died
and trying to incorporate them into your
own life into your own character
as part of the morning process and that
builds you bigger as a person so the
whole proportionately gets smaller and I
think all of us
and my family tried to do that we were
also schools from we were very little to
never complain you know that my mother
would say to us
there are kids in Harlem and watts and
in Compton who lose their mother and
their father and they don't have the
family we have and they don't have the
educational opportunities and you know
everybody takes their licks in life and
you know they you have to have a mission
and you have to keep moving
take the best parts of that person let
me ask you about your father then do you
I mean he was for many people the
greatest president America sadly never
had hi Uncle oh my father your father
your father
what do you think you've gained from him
and do you feel his Spirit guiding you
now as you run for president yeah I mean
I I've spent a lot of time
I think unlike other members of my
family who are who many of them are so
shattered even to this day that they
can't
um really think about my dad's uh you
know death or or my uncle jack
but I've spent a lot of time kind of
reading all the literature and studying
their lives and I
uh I'm constantly
delighted and and surprised by how much
of um of their uh their values have
studied we have wisdom at the test of
time
and I think you know my campaign right
now is about recalling America to those
values and what are they summarize them
well you know all of the kind of
Traditional Values the Democratic party
which are free speech you know A love
for the Constitution
um a uh uh protecting the environment
the purple mountains Majesty for our
children
protecting the government has a overall
old protective rights of minorities and
for uh people who are underrepresented
in the political process
um women's right bodily autonomy you
know
um that
smaller government is and and more
freedom is always better and the word
liberal means freedom and it's uh it's
it and that this idea
that democracy and that you know from a
totalitarian system Fosters human growth
and human creativity so the love of the
Arts which is the highest aspiration of
uh you know of democracy my uncle used
to say that
um that you know nobody really remembers
the names the generals and the
Peloponnesian Wars and the and the
battles you know
but everybody remembers the the poems of
escalation the plays of Sophocles and
um and the art and the sculpture and the
and uh you know in the literature the
beauty of of the uh of the architecture
of ancient Greece and that that really
is the ultimate aspiration of Democratic
Society to create things that are
enduring and that elevate the human
Spirit let's take a show break come back
and talk about what Arts you're good at
then because I know it involves
whitewater kayaking and fortunately what
else do you do Robert F Kennedy Junior
we'll find out
foreign
[Music]
Morgan I'm censored in New York City
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored in
Kiev Ukraine tonight on Piers Morgan's
Special Edition from cancer tonight a
special edition appears more than
uncensored by Tina knows he's making me
cry again do you believe you can win
this war so are you gonna run again I
think a lot of people are going to be
very happy yes I feel betrayed they're
trying to force you out yes not only the
coach but the other two or three guys
there around all these protesting just
don't get it many of them don't it's not
slightly patronizing
I would call it beautiful out the window
do you think we should have psychiatric
assessments
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read
the book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bin
that's sexy where are they where's their
children
where's the castle
it's from that much cushier jail that
Elaine Max will agree to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him you're shaking your
head the British people are up in arms
Boris Johnson is out as British prime
minister the conservative party can
certainly win the next election can we
yes
this is the Royal team question is did
he say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules to give them the
Visa or lied on the visa application
form and therefore got it
[Music]
what does a woman me
let it roll a woman is given to the man
in marriage Andrew You're simply wrong
I've been a terrible liar that's true I
mean would you be prepared to say that
I've been a terrible liar are you sorry
you said that
no I think it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be interview
adjourned
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving us Rhonda sanctimonious
or meatball Rock I've seen you clown
Tommy Fury so please go easy on me bro
please go easy you weren't asked to give
evidence to the grand jury I have
nothing to hire I'm the only one that
has been telling the troops if you had
to come up against a team and had a
Russian player would you shake that no
chance no chance it's life and death
This is
Logan
what went wrong she said well I've only
got two years and I said you'll have two
months if you go on like this what's
your response to him the whole nation
deserves
you don't drink they're taking drugs
you're stinking Rich should we be
concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that was a joke
coming up next on the talk more on the
breaking news that Hugh Edwards is
revealed as the presenter at the center
of the BBC Scandal his wife released a
statement saying he's suffering from
serious mental health issues police say
no criminal offense has been committed
but the BBC will resume its own
investigation more details at nine
o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh looking at
the Empire State Building here in
Manhattan in New York and I'm still with
the presidential candidate Robert F
Kennedy Jr well we left the viewers on a
cliffhanger what are your artistic bents
what are you where do you find your
cultural solace I I
uh well what do you mean I mean I you
know I I I'm I am not particularly
talented as smartest let me put that out
there that's not a big disappointment
people but you know I love like I'm a I
have eclectic days of music and I love
uh art and art history and going to
museums and you know so but I I I I
admire it but I'm not very good at the
falconry is a big thing in your life
yeah what do you get from falconry
I have always had an affinity for the
outdoors and for nature and for me you
know I
read one my uncle was in that white
house there's a lot of people talking
about Camelot and I read th white so in
the once in Future King it's a British
uh Falconer and an incredible writer
and it's about the story of young King
Arthur and there was a chapter there on
falconry on training Hawks which was a
very popular you know in the Middle Ages
it was the most popular sport
and when I read that chapter I fell in
love with it I became obsessed with it
and as it turned out there was a guy who
lived about a mile from my house who was
one of the great pioneers of American
falconry
his name was Alvin I and my father knew
about him he was uh designing jets for
the Pentagon but the uh my father knew
about him because the state department
whenever they were visiting Arab
dignitaries
they would send them to this guy's house
because the Arabs are crazy for falconry
and so I was able because of my father's
contact with them I was able to
Apprentice under him and I learned
Falcon very beginning when I was nine
years what's it giving you falconry it's
uh you know you're it's like being
you're you're with a predatory bird and
you're hunting in the wild usually I'm
out with two birds at a time
and it's like being allowed they don't
change their behavior any any they're
doing nothing that they wouldn't do in
the wild
but you're observing them close up so
it's like being allowed to hunt with a
wolf pack you know where and who
wouldn't want to do that as you see a an
analogy to what you're doing now to the
the other Democratic candidates not
really are you hunting Joe Biden down
like a wolf you know I I
preserving the environment and giving
other kids the opportunity to
to enjoy the richness of those kind of
experience of the outdoors is one that
I'd say the spirit tip of my campaign
that we need to you know we've helped us
through your campaign is your your
youthful vigor and we've seen some uh
tremendous videos of you here in action
working out here which has got everyone
going um I mean obviously we we look at
this and we see a man in Peak physical
condition
um congratulations but we also are
reminded of uh President Biden's but
let's put it kindly lack of comparative
physical condition How concerned are you
never mind the race but how concerned
are you when you see President Biden now
in public the sheer volume of
missteps both verbal and physical does
it concern you as an American the
president seems to be I I don't really
think that I have any
uh additional wisdom to contribute to
that debate I I think that I I don't I
haven't seen President Biden in a couple
of years
and I don't know you know I see I saw
him trip on the stage but you know
anybody could as you know anybody can
trip on that stage and uh and so I don't
really know what his condition is there
are worrying
um you know videos and stuff but uh
would you sense that he may not actually
run in 2020 when it comes to it and is
that why you think you actually have a
real chance of potentially becoming the
Democrat nominee I think I have a chance
of becoming the Democratic nominee
because my numbers
are better at beating Republicans than
him so and I think that's what the
Democracy should the party make him
stand aside for you well I you know
that's first of all that's not going to
happen
oh but doesn't that have to happen to
let you I don't know I mean I I have to
win some primaries and you think you can
actually beat it right I think I can
beat him in the primaries I'm going to
be incredible well I'd be pretty much
unprecedented if you do that right to an
incumbent president it's uh I I think I
think Reagan did that against uh Gerald
Ford right
oh but um yeah I mean it's unusual but
you know my father ran against his
incoming president and he would have won
um and uh you know my Uncle Teddy ran
against incumbent President Carter and
and lost and do you actually believe one
uh he won something like 37 States you
actually believed in
2024 when we get to December January you
will be the person I on inauguration day
addressing the American people okay I'm
gonna be very uh objective about this
but I'm telling you that we have a few
seconds left if I had put money in bed
on any candidate I would put it on me
that's good enough Robert F Kennedy
Junior a great pleasure to meet you I
was a gambling ad well I'm a Gambling
Man a myself good to see you
uh whatever you up to keep it
unsensitive good night
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign